[Music]
ethos is a bone grafting material used
in dental surgery
usually around the placement of dental
implants where the patient is missing
bone
that needs to be regenerated to get a
secure fixture
for the implant the material was
developed by a dentist dr peter
fairburne
who's been using crafting materials for
over 20 years in his practice
so had a very good grasp of what the
material needed to do
to make things easier for the dentist to
give the best patient outcomes
[Music]
our aims are simple we want to help
teachers
by making their working lives easier we
want to help
students by supporting their development
as effective learners
we believe that by learning on their own
terms
in a way that is native to them students
can increase their educational
attainment and improve their life
chances
[Music]
at the start of lockdown our team
quickly flagged up they were struggling
to work from home
and one of them came up with the idea of
making a pop-up desk within a couple of
weeks we designed
and built a designed the desk built an
online website and we're selling these
to consumers with nothing but five star
reviews
since then companies like ryman big doug
and b and q
have all listed our products and as
people came out of lockdown
we applied our newfound confidence in
innovation
to making products like the the
distancing at work screens
and the signage we also launched a new
brand called the paper hive which was
aimed specifically at consumers
what we are able to offer is something
that nobody else is able to offer in the
marketplace at the moment because we can
provide an integrated solution from end
to end
so that includes what i described as
being the charging element
and right the way through to the um
ownership of the back
of the bus and being able to provide
that but all the software that connects
right across
[Music]
you